investigation now
as we all know much more needs to be
done
but we have made great progress in this
year
just to say one of the most important
four-letter words in our economy is jobs
and as you can see and i hope you can
all see
uh from 2020
this was the job situation
2021
6 million
400 000 jobs
an unemployment rate that has gone down
to three
by 3.4
uh percent
millions more americans back to work
3.9 percent of the uncle and then now of
course with legislation that is pending
we hope
uh that when we have more access to
child care and universal pre-k and the
rest many more people will be able to go
to work uh especially as the president
addresses
uh continues to address the coveted uh
challenge that we have that are keeping
people out of work but 6.4
million jobs versus
practically over five million
six million jobs just
the year before in the previous
presidency
so with that many more people
availing themselves of the affordable
care act and tune of millions more
people five million more people we're
very proud of that
and uh
and having access to quality health care
force more to come when we pass some
version
of the legislation that is pending over
on
the senate side
uh we're very proud in the course of
well almost a year ago
on march a year we passed the
recovery rescue package the rescue
package put money in the pockets of the
american people vaccines in their arms
many more children safely back to school
people back to work
it enabled cities states and counties
how to uh pay for
and support
the systems that make
societies work whether it's the
education of our children the
transportation of our people
of the
first responders our security our
security our security food workers the
list goes on of services that are
provided by localities and counties as
well as states uh they took many
millions of people young children out of
poverty
the rescue package did just that
rescue our economy our society and our
people as it assault attacked the covet
crisis
as you all know we've had a variant that
has prolonged the crisis
i'm very proud of the work that the
president is doing now to make sure that
people have tests and masks and
hopefully more people will avail
themselves of vaccinations
more therapies are in the works and in
terms of not having to have
refrigeration of the kind that is almost
impossible to have throughout the world
we salute our scientists for what they
are doing
science and governance that's going to
be solved
uh solves that problem so for these and
other reasons whether it's broadband or
clean water as we know when the and the
bipartisan
the first bill the rescue package was
taking people out of poverty money in
pockets and all the rest that was done
with
not one republican vote
there were 13 republican votes in the
house to support
the infrastructure bill and we were
happy that that was bipartisan so we
could repair roads and bridges this
improved public transit secure clean
water broadband and much more across the
country there's a great deal
to be um
to be
proud of but as with all of this we
always keep an eye on what needs to be
done
to meet the kitchen table needs of the
american people what keeps them up at
night
we want to help solve that problem and
one of the
proud things about this administration
is the creation of job the expansion of
health care
and again the alleviation
of poverty
so with that and we'll go on to
uh what we want to do next uh there's no
question last night was a disappointment
i support what the president said is
disappointed but not deterred
we will continue the work
uh we will follow the example of those
uh who went before us in terms of the
fight for civil rights and voting rights
not to be deterred
so the fight goes on i had the privilege
earlier this week at the beginning of
the week on martin luther king day to be
with the king family to be inspired over
and over again continue to be inspired
by them uh to the point of the regret
martin luther king's granddaughter you
wanted was 13 years old in eighth grade
talking about the future
talking with her great wisdom about the
future
so we're again always
eager to do more but nonetheless
disappointed what happened but i want to
congratulate
leader schumer
for his courage
for how he proceeded with this
legislation had you had to have a goal
and what was wonderful to see was for
almost two days to hear the democratic
senators talk about the sanctity of the
vote and how fundamental that is
to our democracy it was so inspiring
sad though to hear the republicans argue
against the uh the uh
freedom to vote and protect our vote
whatever the outcome the fact is is that
every democrat voted
every democrat in the senate voted
for the the
freedom to vote slash
john lewis voter advancement act and
every republican voted against it
uh
the process in the senate has much means
much to be desired if you want to talk
about that again later
but the fact is
is that
it was an inspiring day and i salute
that uh the the chairman uh for bringing
that important legislation to the
forefront as he brought it to the floor
and that's a way to get it into the
forefront it's so important
but
again my motto is some of you heard me
say it we don't agonize we organize and
that's what we will do to again advance
uh voter participation in our country as
a former chair of the party our goal was
to remove obstacles of participation for
anyone whatever their party was to
remove obstacles and participate instead
of what the republicans are doing is to
put up obstacles for participation so
the fight for voting rights continues we
will not resent and the fight goes on
so where do we go from here
as we have been engaged in all of these
highly
visible fights
discussions debates in the congress we
have been
working in many cases in a bipartisan
way to advance legislation which should
be coming to the floor
uh in the in the months ahead as soon as
uh the um
we come to the
the agreement first and foremost is the
omnibus bill i salute our chair rose it
to laurel for the work that she is doing
was has to be bipartisan and as an
appropriator myself
from way back i always say left to their
own devices the appropriators can get
the job done and we're going to leave
them to their own devices and i hope
that mitch mcconnell will lead them up
to their devices as well uh we must get
that done it is it is important for in
terms of governance to get the
appropriations built done the omnibus
bill
done to fund the government it is now
the national security issue
of the highest priority with the threats
that exist out there to go to a
continuing resolution instead of
decision making omnibus bill is to
weaken our security and our stability
the republicans should know that so we
hope that we will be able to bring that
legislation to the floor uh before
it expires
honoring our pact this is another
security issue it's about the burn pits
this is something that members have been
working on for a while and now yesterday
even in fact the
veterans affairs committee had a realms
chairman mr chicano had killed chicano
had
a round table with the dso the veteran
service organizations we thank our
veterans and our veteran services
organizations for their input on this as
you know
many of our service members were
affected by being exposed to burn pits
and
we have had legislation passed it will
be expensive
but is the price we must pay
that we owe our veterans to make sure
they get the care and benefits that they
deserve of those who are exposed to burn
pits and from our standpoint if you were
there you qualify we don't have to go
through any torturous uh
process to decide if somebody
illness depended on something that they
were exposed to
that very important legislation again
we're hoping all of this is bipartisan
the competitiveness bill
it has many names uh it's about chips
about funding for chips it's about
research and development research
a very big piece of that coming out of
our science space and technology
committee under leadership of eddie
bernice chairwoman eddie bernice johnson
it's about
supply chain uh and it's it's pretty
exciting uh that the competitiveness
bill and we're very close
to being ready to go to conference with
the senate on that legislation
postal reform you've heard about it over
and over again but again it's about
fairness and making sure that we have
fairness for our postal workers without
having the retirement health benefits be
pre-funded for 75 years
into the future
these are some of the items on the
agenda in the very near future
that have
important ramifications for us
very important in terms of all of this
is what we do about
any legislation we may have about the
ukraine which is really about our
security and our stability mr menendez
has legislation in the senate
we anticipate a companion bill in the
house but that's up to mr our
distinguished chairman mr makes uh to
announce
we have
had members have been meeting committees
of security committees have been meeting
we've had our briefings and the rest
and uh
when the legislation is ready whenever
that may be it could be next week
it could be next month but whenever it
is ready
we will go forward with legislation in
terms of the stability and national
security whether it's legislation on
robust russian sanctions
assistance to ukraine
again
our commitments to nato and so forth so
that's uh the violence
acknowledge
and appreciate what joe biden as
president united states the difference
that he has made 6.4 million jobs that
has a
nice ring to it we want more we can put
more people back to work when we have
more access to child care and and
home health care so that moms and dads
can be in the workforce and when we
solve and crush the kovich crisis which
is a deterrent to people going to work
as well
so we thank the president for his great
leadership we appreciate the leadership
of chuck schumer in advancing the
sanctity of the vote in the senate and
giving it the visibility that it would
never have had without having a vote uh
in the senate
as as we prepare
for what's next on our agenda we do so
striving for as much bipartisanship as
possible in terms of protecting our
honoring our veterans protecting our
country
again
funding the governance of our country on
a happy note
yesterday congress passed legislation to
award willie oh you you know william
you know
you just destroyed that one
well you come to our office later today
because i will be signing the
legislation and he was for the
information willie oe was the first
black player in the national hockey
league the congressional gold medal we
voted on it yesterday i signed the bill
today he was referred to as the jackie
robinson of hockey
we could never have a meeting without
talking sports
but
the house passed the bill unanimously
which honors the contribution of a
sports legend who broke the nh national
hockey league's color barrier despite
being legally blind in one eye
is that remarkable so we'll have the
signing do you know what's happening
i'm sorry he had four goals
good for you well
i'm just staying up late at night
watching warriors and stuff like that
but
anyone any questions
yes sir uh madam speaker i understand
that last thursday you asked the medium
house administration
say to the members of your caucus which
range from frontline members to some of
the most progressive members who want to
go further and enact them well i don't
know that i mean that's your version
here's the thing
i say to my members
on a regular basis when we gather in
caucus and as you know sometimes it's
hybrid these days but anytime we have
gathered in caucus when we're actually
virtually a hybrid i've said to them
under this rule figuratively or actually
is the greatest collection
of intellect
integrity
and imagination for doing the right
thing for the american people
i have great
confidence in the contegrity of my
members
they
are remarkable
so when people talk about well somebody
might do this and somebody i
i said i trust our members if in fact we
should have severe
penalties for delay and reporting on
stock then do that i said to the the
house administration committee review
all the bills that are coming in and see
which ones
where where the support is in our caucus
um
i think there are two letters each has
like 14 members signing it so far maybe
more will come but that's what we have
seen but i do
i do come down always in favor of
trusting our members now if the
impression that is given by some that
somebody's doing inside of here that's a
nation that's a
justice department issue
take that's a justice department issue
and and that that has no place in any of
this
but to give a blanket
attitude of
we can't do this and we can't do that
because we can't be trusted i just don't
buy into that but if members want to do
that i'm okay with it how about what add
and i would add and this is the last
thing i'm going to say on this
at this meeting and i would add
do you know that the supreme court now
we in the house
have disclosure
in the congress we have disclosure and
we have the stock act which says if you
sell a a
stock you have to report it in x number
of days and if not there's a penalty
should those penalties be greater
subject to review i mean
i don't know why they people don't do it
on time but whatever it is there's a
penalty and it should be more severe so
big but the
united states supreme court
where decisions are made
all the time that affect
our environment our workforce
our personal freedoms
every subject you can name at the mercy
of the court
our
economic issues and the rest
no disclosure whatsoever
and certainly no stock act
i don't know is that if we're saying
everybody should be living by the same
standard then that so be it that's okay
with me
but i don't think that the court should
be let off the hook and even this the
chief justice wreck rep
said recently that their the impression
was that there were some scandals in
judges making decisions that related in
a way that wasn't right so i say when we
go forward with anything let's take the
supreme court with us
to have disclosure no disclosure
the supreme court of the united states
for life no disclosure
and certainly therefore no stockholders
right
on another subject
the president indicated yesterday
chunks of it get passed
i'm sure you heard what he said i i
wonder what you think of that statement
and
i had a couple of parts here he said the
child tax credit free community colleges
might drop out and just what should we
expect when it comes to the bbb going
forward
well let me just say
chunks is an interesting word
the president
has such a commitment to the values that
are contained in the in this legislation
the legislation the reconciliation bill
uh when that we passed the
the um and when they were considering
and then later we passed the bipartisan
infrastructure bill the president said
i want to find as much common ground as
i can
in a bipartisan way
when it comes to infrastructure
but i cannot
limit my vision for america
to what the republicans will agree to in
terms of roads and bridges etc that's
important
but it's not all
so in this legislation
if we care about preserving the planet
for future generations and clean air for
them to breathe today and water to drink
we need to pass
the reconciliation bill
so i would hope that that would be a
major part of it so what the president
calls chunks i would hope would be a
major
bill going forward it may be more
limited
but it is
still significant so we talked about
climate now let's talk about health care
so important in the legislation is that
millions more people will have access to
health care at a very low cost
because of what is in the bill in terms
of
expanding the affordable care act let's
now talk about child care
child care in the bill whether you're
talking about the child tax credit or
you're talking about child care or
you're talking about home health care
that might include a child or an older
sibling or a parent
or you're talking about
universal pre-k
all of this
lowers cost
lowers costs for care
and is transformative in the lives
especially of women in the workforce so
we have to have
if our economy is going to succeed as
you know we say when women succeed
america succeeds if we're going to have
the full benefit of women and newcomers
and when i say newcomers people of color
who have not been in some of these
traditional jobs to expand what that
means we have to have
care at home
whether it's for children or again older
siblings or parents so this
there are big chunks of
of the bill that have to be contained
but remember this
that this is a reconciliation bill
so when people say let's divide it up
yeah
they'll understand the process
what can we agree upon
and i'm sure that we can agree upon
something significant
call it a chunk if you want
but whatever you call it
we want it to be able to make a
difference
in transforming the workplace
uh by honoring work
by respecting the fact that their
families that have to make decisions
between home and work and again
protecting the planet so i'm optimistic
i'm optimistic
yes
very disappointed
i think people will say what they're
going to say i have not encouraged that
in fact i have discouraged it
because we are a giant kaleidoscope here
democrats and republicans you never know
who's going to be in the design of the
next bill uh and and so we have to be
respectful uh but i have not i've
discouraged people from making comments
about them and i you maybe hear it more
than i do i just don't hear that much of
it anymore
no i don't think so i i don't think so i
think that they'll do what they believe
and if they and i'm hopeful they have
come to agreement on aspects of the uh
build that better legislation we may
want to have to rename it to something
that's
even built back better than that kind of
whatever we decide to call it but the
fact is is that uh uh
you know it's a it's a
we're a diverse place from right to left
democrats to republicans within our own
parties and the rest and we have to be
respectful and i don't think there's any
other and the upside in democrats
criticizing democrats
well i as i said earlier right right
away we have been working on legislation
right now to keep government open in a
way that meets the needs of the american
people that protects the security and
stability of our country
and that is legislation that we hope
will be on the floor in a short period
of time and i thank rosa delauro for
that a high priority for us is to honor
the pact
to make sure that our men and women in
uniform who were exposed to burn pits
understand that this is of the highest
priority for us it's going to be very
costly
but it's worth it because we owe them
they were exposed in the in their in the
line of duty uh to dangerous situations
where they now have serious uh
health issues and they need
care and benefits uh i mentioned also
the the issue that relates to
competitiveness
this is really important
for us in terms of
chips and what that means to our
manufacturing base in terms of supply
chain which that means what that means
to our economy and research which which
means to our present and to our future
these are big all of these are big bills
the the
trillion and a half
for the omnibus bill probably over half
a trillion dollars for burn pits we
don't know we're waiting for further uh
uh cbo scores
on that and then in terms of the
competes act that's a 50 billion dollars
for chips and other 40 billion dollars
perhaps for supply
chain so these are significant bills
that um contain
especially that omnibus and the
competitiveness bills they're bills that
contain large numbers of other bills
large numbers of other bills but they
are the vehicle that will take us
forward under the title of
competitiveness was it called in the
senate
you seek
in the senate and uh we call it
competitive still here whatever the
title or we hope to go to conference on
that soon and then there are other bills
that relate to the postal service and
the rest again about governance
but we have always been about america's
working families so we still want to
pass a legislation uh that expands our
workforce by
recognizing responsibilities that people
have at home which i
address so i went over some that are in
the near
near future we have three task force
that works
select committee task force that are not
legislative committees but will make
recommendations one of them is the um
the select committee on the climate
crisis
and much of what they have recommended
is in
uh the current version of the bbb we
hope that most of that survives but that
isn't the end of it there will be other
own uh
opportunities shall we say that we will
have to help other countries uh to to
save the planet as well so not
nothing is the end game but it is uh
takes us well down the path in terms of
the select and that's chaired by kathy
castro of florida she's doing a
superlative job next we have the kind of
the thought committee on covet and the
leadership of mr
mr um
clyburn are distinguished wit and they
are doing very important work that helps
us make judgments about what has worked
better or what in terms of how we go
forward in terms of this pandemic but
any future ones as well and then we have
a select committee on disparity uh an
income and opportunity in our country
chaired by mr hines and you'll see much
more of that
now that we've gotten through some of
the uh
hopefully soon some of the big
legislation uh coming out of the last
year and that is what led how we affect
legislation to end that disparity of
opportunity in our country uh the fact
that and during the con provide crisis
wealth increased at the high end to such
an exorbitant place at the expense of
people
not i don't say at the low end but a
lower economic uh
place on our in our society
we can't have that continue that's
that's what is a caste system that's not
a democracy the middle class
is the backbone of our democracy
we have to strengthen the middle class
and all who aspire to it so that is what
our legislation is about so how we
protect our nation how we preserve our
planet how we transform our workforce
how we educate our children
my whole mission in congress is about
the children for the children as you
heard me say
you're in the arena you have to be
prepared to take a punch
you have to be prepared to throw a punch
for the children
for the children and so we'll be dealing
with issues that relate to
antitrust and to section 230 and what
damage that does to children and the
rest but i'm very proud of our
committees they're working very hard on
their legislation some of it they will
bring individually to the floor somewhat
as with the competitive math act that's
a that's a bill from science space and
technology energy and commerce education
and labor
and other committees as well so some of
this will be jointly some of it will be
individually
los angeles
[Music]
[Music]
yeah thank you for that question because
uh and many of our committees in the
judiciary committee for sure and
education and workforce and all of our
committees
community safety
is of the highest priority
as a value
the form of the legislation it will take
remains to be seen as i said our
committees will be working on these
issues but community safety
right up there with jobs and health care
and the rest community safety very
important
that's why we were very proud that in
the
rescue package we had significant
funding for a state and local government
which was funding our first responders
largely our police and fire uh we have
to be strong in that respect
we have to be strong in that respect but
in the
in the bbb
there's very important language and i
refer you to it about how we address
criminal justice and the rest
in our country but thank you for asking
that question we can have a whole day
and we probably will
on that subject because community safety
our first responsibility is to protect
and defend whether that's our national
security or our community safety we have
to keep the american people safe thank
you all very much